how did you meet your group wife I met
her on a dating app she curved me for
two years this woman curved me for two
years
just said next one you know she matched
me I told a joke she said haha I said
what's what's really good let's hang out
sometime curved no response two years
they do that every Raya
no one responds to me curved yeah is
that what it is I've been curved Pella
then she came back but then she came
back two years later and was like I'm
what I'm gonna do is pretend like you
know I didn't just ignore this for two
years and I was like all right cool I'm
gonna play hard to get so I waited three
hours oh wow was that hard it was it was
the first hour was cool second hour got
harder in the third hour I was just
jerking off to her Instagram but at this
point you should respond so so when you
when you took her out were you nervous
was I nervous yeah no because she curved
me twice I said two dates and she didn't
make either of them and had really
really good excuses both times so the
third time I was just like listen I'm
gonna go boxing if you want to come and
she's like actually I would love to do
that so then went boxing and then
like we went to the gym and boxed it was
cool oh yeah he boxes like you boxed yes
she put on gloves and you boxing each
other yeah well we we trained but she
does spar me like we do this thing where
she gets to hit me and I just eat it
it's called a relationship yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
you're very funny no I'm not funny yeah
you're doing it's because your mic's
taking out the notes so no it's my time
I'm not just funny without your mic
okay
yeah so that's how because let me ask
why do you guys do that do what like if
you like it's on Royal what happens is
you'll you'll see a purple thing can I
tell you at least for me I like you
right so then I'll like them back right
I go or whatever with excellent
exclamation exclamation right and
nothing ever ever that's a terrible
thing I'm about to say but truly the
only reason
um the only purpose of Raya for me is
just an ego boost yeah like there's no I
have no interest in having a real
conversation every it's just I I hate it
I'm just like oh oh my God how fun and
then next like I'm out
then just don't swipe then don't say you
like somebody
I mean I like their pictures I like
their pictures of them oh that's a cute
dog well it's sometimes what that does
to guys is like oh kalilah oh my God I
mean I'm hoping you need action
everybody needs a little action you know
like what do you mean action just you
know you need somebody to be like
matching you you know like matching
right that's what Tinder watch them and
leave them right there yeah I just I I
have no desire to go okay dates but I
don't take it personally anymore I mean
I I just know that that's the game do
you do any online like I mean is it just
Riot or like all online dating is like I
mean I was banned from two of them but
yeah I've always on Tinder and uh Raya
yeah but you know what I'm not even
hanging out with people on those anymore
on Tinder on any of them oh because you
got banned no I know on the computer
what's bad oh you got banned yeah I got
banned from hinge and Bumble but
um the last couple of dates are people
that I've just met on the street not
homeless we all have so much
self-control to do this I could not do
this with an X X's the x's and then
talking about your dating to each other
that's I don't know if I could do that
what do you mean
why can't you like if it ever knock on
wood if it ever happened no it would not
happen with me and my girl because yeah
forever you know but like
yeah I mean go ahead I have something to
say but go ahead I think the reason it's
a little easier for us because it's like
we let the record play to the very end
like there is a feeling of closure and
completion I think it would have been
hard if there were still if it was not
like a mutual like we we knew it was
over like we we're in therapy for two
years and that our I guess in a sense
our therapist was just kind of preparing
us for the end wow
yeah wow also that is true though
couples therapy is either they fix your
relationship or you're paying them to
get you out of it civilly I also got in
a fight with faheem an or I'm gonna say
their names I don't care
female Anwar and [__] Harlan Williams
are they the comedians that tried to
pull up on her no I remember that from
episode that podcast has gotten better
though in a way because it's like every
couple episodes or something you guys
get to like how you guys are doing and
that's like the show now I just have to
tell you this is better like you guys
did I got in a fight with Harlan
Williams Anwar and they were like
because I was telling them that kalila
still lives there for a while
yeah right and I go yeah what's the big
deal and they're like oh if that was me
I would never talk to her again I would
cut ties and this and I go yep that's
how you do relationships yeah they've
also never been in a decade-long
relationship or like started a business
together with somebody with animals it
doesn't matter because look at me and
Sarah uh Highland right you guys he's
you're friends I'm very good friends
with other acts it's like I oh man Bobby
got a pattern
oh you son of a [__] I'm kidding